Groot the lovable and sentient tree-like
creature that captured our hearts and
the Guardians of the Galaxy franchise
but what species is Groot and what does
his life cycle look like I'm
in this video we'll explore the
fascinating evolution of this beloved
character first let's start at the
beginning when we first meet Groot in
the 2014 film Guardians of the Galaxy
he's a fully grown tree creature who can
only say three words I am Groot but how
did he come to be in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 we learned that Groot is
actually part of a species known as
Flora Colossus native to the Planet X
these creatures are essentially sentient
trees capable of regrowing from even the
smallest of cuttings this particular
Flora Colossus Groot became involved
with rocket a skilled criminal and had
formed a fast friendship with the two
becoming partners in crime later on
Groot joined the Guardians of the Galaxy
a team of galactic heroes very few
beings in the known universe are able to
converse with floor Colossus due to
their unique vocabulary with Rocket
Raccoon being an expert in it so his
vocabulistics is limited to i and m and
groups exclusively in that order
eventually the other members of the
Guardians of the Galaxy begin to pick up
on it as well as shown when they scolded
Groot for his foul language Thor also
says that he knows the language after
having learned it in Asgard implying the
other asgardians may know the line
language as well this language seems to
be tonal where a spoken phrase can mean
many things and is incomprehensible to
the untrained ear Flora colossi are
formidable creatures with tough
tree-like exteriors that afford them
incredible physical strength and
durability their body structure is
robust and resilient making them almost
invulnerable to physical harm they
possess a highly accelerated healing
Factor allowing them to regrow Limbs and
even their entire bodies from just a
tiny fragment these creatures have
complete control over their bodies and
can extend their limbs as Vines to reach
high places or as whip-like Weapons they
can also grow Twigs on any part of their
body as a threat display or Shield
change their body shape grow leaves or
flowers and release bioluminescent
Airborne seeds Flora colossi are
incredibly strong able to lift heavy
objects including several men with just
one arm their height is composed of wood
that's dense and durable enough to make
them immune to most Conventional Weapons
including gunfire and fire which would
consume most other woods they can endure
the loss of entire limbs apparently
without experiencing any pain like I
mentioned before these creatures have an
amazing healing fact Vector allowing
them to regenerate everything from a
missing limb to their entire body
additionally they can produce tiny
phosphorescent spores that float through
the air and offer enough ambient light
to illuminate a small area they normally
take the shape of a large tree-like
humanoid but can also weave their limbs
into a dense tangle of vines when Gru
sacrificed himself at the end of
Guardians of the Galaxy rocket kept a
small piece of his body and replanted it
causing a new sapling to be grown from
his previous form this little sapling
quickly became a fan favorite due to his
lovable personality and innocence
leading to his incorporation into tons
of merchandise and Comics one of his
most endearing qualities though is his
love for music and dancing in the
post-credits scene for Guardians of the
Galaxy he danced to the famous song I
Want You Back by the Jackson 5. but we
also learned that he's shy when it comes
to dancing in front of Drax in this
scene we see sapling start to dance only
to stop abruptly when he realizes Drax
is watching him we later learned that he
does this because Drax fell in love with
his wife when his entire tribe was
dancing at a gathering except for her he
knew she was the one because she wasn't
dancing and Groot even in his young
sapling form understands this important
fact about tracks this moment highlights
sapling group's vulnerability and adds
depth to the character Beyond just being
cute and fun loving but groot's life
cycle doesn't stop there and the second
Guardians movie were introduced to a new
version of the character baby Groot Baby
Groot is smaller in size and often
portrayed as having a more innocent and
playful personality while he may look
cute and innocent he's still a member of
the Flora Colossus species and he's
capable of growing into a fully grown
tree creature just like his predecessor
Baby Groot also loves music and when
it's taken away he's shown to have a
pretty short temper
[Music]
despite this short temper we also see
baby groot's fun-loving and curious side
throughout the films and the short
series I am grew on Disney Plus in
Avengers Infinity War we see Groot as a
teenager showing signs of growth and
maturity as he helps the Guardians of
the Galaxy fight against Thanos Tinker
is more angsty and Moody than his baby
counterpart and he's shown to be
preoccupied with playing video games the
entire time hey
however despite his more difficult
personality he remains a key member of
the Guardians of the Galaxy team and his
skills in combat and the ability to grow
his limbs to Great size make him a
formidable force to be reckoned with
tinker's appearance and personality
continue to add another level of
complexity to the already intricate
Guardians of the Galaxy this version of
Groot is in his young adult stage and
Falls somewhere between the previously
seen teen group and adult group he has a
little bit more of a sophisticated and
mature personality than his teen form
while still keeping the charm and humor
that has made his character a fan
favorite young adult Groot is again a
part of the Beloved Guardians of the
Galaxy team and his role in the holiday
special was pretty entertaining adult
Groot is the original version of the
character from the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he first appeared in the movie
Guardians of the Galaxy as a mature and
wise character he possesses immense
strength and the ability to manipulate
trees and other plant life unlike his
younger forms Ado is a fully grown
tree-like humanoid with a deep voice and
a calm demeanor throughout the Marvel
series adult group plays a vital role in
helping the Guardians and his friends
save the Galaxy from various villains
his sacrifice in the first guardians of
the Galaxy film where he gave his life
to save his friends was one of the most
emotional moments in the entire MCU
[Music]
ordering and sentient tree-like creature
from a parallel universe who rules as
the Invincible master of plants and acts
as the king of Planet X standing at a
height of at least 60 feet tall his
thick bark covered body boasts long
gnarled branches as arms and twisted
Roots as legs crowned with a knotted
mass of branches and glowing green
golden eyes King Groot radiates pulsing
green Vines and leaves displaying his
immense Powers though Savage and
ferocious in appearance he's actually a
thoughtful and Gentle Leader who only
uses his strength for the betterment of
his people unlike his Guardians of the
Galaxy counterpart this alternate
version of Groot has become a galactic
warlord capturing humans for
experimentation however he was
eventually captured himself and taken to
battle realm where he became a
participant in the game contest of
Champions while this is an alternate
version of Groot himself Groot could
grow into a creature as large as this
from his birth as a sapling to his
eventual adulthood and rebirth Groot
experiences numerous Transformations as
a part of his natural life cycle and who
knows what the future holds for Groot
one thing's for sure though groot's life
cycle is a testament to the incredible
resilience and adaptability of the Flora
Colossus species
[Music]